caroline senior responsable d'une agence
de voyage dans le 7e arrondissement de
paris the travel corner bonsoir caroline
seigneur merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france je le disais vous
êtes responsable d'une agence de voyage
alors déjà ce que vous avez enfin repris
le travail
les affaires reprennent tél oui depuis
hier
alors les affaires qu'elle reprenne je
peux pas vous dire parce que depuis le
mois de mars on est un petit peu sur le
qui vive après on commence déjà à avoir
des nouvelles demandes pour plutôt
octobre noël février l'année prochaine
et après faut plutôt gérer les reports
de cet été alors justement cet été ça
intéresse beaucoup de monde évidemment
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui vous
passez votre temps à rassurer les
personnes à gérer comme vous dites des
reports est ce que on imagine qu'à
différents cas de figure beaucoup vont
rester en france beaucoup vont partir en
europe expliqué nous un petit peu la
situation d'ensemble et on ira dans le
détail après bas après je dirais que ça
dépend de ce que les gens vont réserver
si vous voulez pour des personnes qui
ont réservé à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen
aujourd'hui on sait que maintenant ça va
être possible donc sur l'italie
l'espagne la grèce les voyages vont
pouvoir être maintenu avec des
meilleures conditions que ce qui a été
annoncé auparavant
par contre pour tout ce qui va être en
dehors de l'espace schengen
malheureusement on est encore en attente
des décisions de chaque gouvernement si
vous voulez comme le brésil ou les états
unis ou d'autres pays d'ailleurs
alors comment sont justement par par
l'europe
évidemment on sait que l'italie
l'espagne la grèce sont des hauts lieux
touristiques la france également
ça veut dire quoi ce vrai que les
français qui vont aller
à l'intérieur des frontières européennes
vont peut-être avoir des contraintes ou
tout élevé et ils pourront passer des
vacances quasi normal dans ces pays là
je dirais pas ça c'est plutôt en
fonction des ja de la politique de
chaque pays aujourd'hui on sait que la
la grèce donc aujourd'hui maintiennent
comme vous avez dit dans votre reportage
ils maintiennent les tests et tout ça
aujourd'hui mais à compter du 1er
juillet il y en aura plus sauf si
deuxième vannes bien évidemment parce
qu'après chaque pays va adapter sa
politique en fonction de la situation
d'un évident après tous les pays de
l'espace schengen n'ont pas encore
rouvert notamment pour nous les français
et comme l'a rappelé notre président la
réciprocité se passera de toute façon si
un pays ne nous accepte pas ça sera la
même chose dans ce sens inverse
clairement le gouvernement le santé
avait envie de favoriser les
destinations françaises on imagine que
c'est toujours le cas est ce que
justement les français vont répondre
présents et sont nombreux à vouloir
rester sur le territoire
alors pour beaucoup fin de mes clients
en tout cas une majorité
après pour le reste ça reste des clients
si vous voulez les français en moyenne
sont quand même des voyageurs et je
doute que tous veuillent rester en
france parce que étant donné qu'on veut
maximiser le tourisme en france
vous en avez beaucoup qui veulent fuir
le tourisme un peu de masse après je
peux pas dire qu'en france on parce que
du tourisme de masse non plus mais le
fait est de se retrouver sur des plages
avec énormément de monde je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de français qui ont préféré
aller en grèce sur des plages ou you're
a person who allez découvrir justement
santorin avec beaucoup moins de monde
les bateaux qui aura qui seront déjà
plus là cet été je pense
je pense que ça sera ça marchera bien
aussi alors il ya peut-être est-ce
qu'ils auront envie d'aller encore plus
loin
aujourd'hui les frontières de schengen
ont rouvert vous vous l'avez dit c'est
pas encore très claire quelles sont les
destinations qui paraissent crédibles
cet été en tout cas
voilà crédible on va dire je cherchais
le mot paix mais on voit là bas pour le
moment hors schengen le seul qui pour le
moment est en pourparlers et j'espère
positivement ça reste l'indonésie après
comme chaque année les grosses
destination qui fonctionne ça reste les
états unis le canada le brésil
aujourd'hui le brésil et les états unis
ça semble un petit peu compliqué mais
après on ne sait pas en avance je vous
avoue au jour le jour
après le canada semble aussi enclins à
ouvrir ses portes donc avoir vraiment
tous les jours ça change donc je pense
qu'il faut qu'on s'adapte avec la
situation au jour le jour
par exemple la deuxième vague en asie du
sud est ce que ça peut changer justement
la donne sur ses long-courriers sur
l'indonésie je verrai pas vraiment
pourquoi parce que depuis le début du
coffee ils ont quand même été peu touché
par rapport à nous très peu de cas
finalement par rapport à l'europe ni
même par rapport à la chine
aujourd'hui la chine a plus sa faim
souhaite on aurait une deuxième vague ça
veut pas dire que ça va toucher non plus
tous les pays de l'asie du sud-est ou
même aller jusqu au japon en corée tout
ça je doute une destination dont on n'a
pas parlé mais qui intéresse beaucoup de
français également des français
d'origine du maghreb
quelle est la situation notamment pour
la tunisie et le maroc le maroc pour le
moment de ce que je sais les frontières
sont encore fermés je n'ai pas de
visibilité sur sur l'été la tunisie
parle d'une éventuelle ouverture pour le
moment on attend les informations de
toute façon du gouvernement alors à
moins d'aller en bretagne il faudra
s'armer de patience si on ad'un compris
merci caroline seigneur responsable de
l'agencé travaille corner dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris merci à vous